Professor Peterson,
just a two second.
Thank you very much for my
community and the Jewish community.
So many people have been inspired by you
to be better people and I wouldn't be
able to speak to you that saying that.
So thank you very much.
Um,
a couple of things.
The first thing I wanted to do is make
a quick comment that you might find
interesting that in the
Jewish astrological calendar,
um,
we read the release cycle of the five
books of Moses and it just so happens that
we are reading this part of the,
of the tourist story.
Very interesting.
That's cool.
And a synchronistic,
which brings me into a question
that I wanted to ask you about,
which is one question with two
parts about your knowledge of,
of,
of Hebrew.
Um,
because if you look at the Torah
scrolls that you find in the synagogue,
there are no vowels,
there are no sentences there.
It is a,
it is chaos,
chaos and order is trying
to be bought into it.
I'm wondering how knowledge
knowledgeable are you of the Hebrew,
which has many layers of,
of,
of dimension staggering
the ignorant of it.
So you know,
I read a lot of commentaries,
right?
I'm trying to zero in on the,
like with each of the phrases
that we went through today,
I probably looked at 10
different commentaries.
And so,
and then I have this underlying
psychoanalytic knowledge
that it's sort of like
if you have a bunch of different templates
to look at things through and then
something shines through all
those templates at the same time,
that's very unlikely.
And so then you can,
you know,
a coincidence is one thing,
but five coincidence is that's
no longer a coincidence.
That's something else.
And so I think,
I'm hoping that despite
the fact that there's many,
many things that I don't know that there's
enough things that I do know to kind
of weave my way through this
with some degree of utility,
if not certainty.
Yeah.
Cause I just,
which is the second part,
which I guess maybe you don't know,
but the,
the Midrash,
the Jewish oral stories that date
back almost as long as these stories,
which filling a lot of
mindblowingly crazy,
random,
so many details about these stories.
And I was just wondering if you had
encountered any of them before I've
encountered some of them,
but again,
it's a,
it's well,
as you know,
it's a very,
very rich tradition.
And so I haven't encountered enough of it.
Were you thinking of anything in specific
specifically in relationship to this
story?
Not In particular.
I actually forgot it.
I was,
I was intending to bring you a,
a book of midrashic stolen.
That's a hell of a thing to say now.
Well,
it just,
I dunno.
I,
I felt like I had to say that.
Um,
but yeah,
maybe for the exodus version,
I'll bring you the bird.
All right.
That would be good.
Yeah.
Okay.